hey there my name is max and i'm joined
today by
jordan hello and today we're going to be
talking about apex legends
season 7. now we got the chance to play
early and we got to see a lot
of the new content coming to apex
legends right now we know there's a
whole bunch of stuff coming such as
clubs
new battle pass new vehicle a new legend
new map
jordan what do you think of the map so
far i really
like olympus from what we've seen so far
we only had a few
hours of hands-on time but it's exciting
for the first
time in a really long time apex legends
feels like it's on the brink of
delivering us
something completely brand new olympus
is
this fat chunky boy of a map it's
bigger than king's canyon but smaller
than
world's edge so world's edge will still
hold the title as the largest map
in apex legends it's not really divided
into halves the same way
that kings canyon and world's edge are
it's more like these
distinct zones these biomes all around
the outside and they all surround this
one
giant location kind of in the middle and
it creates a very
different looking map as well as a very
like different type of
loot chase that you have when you decide
to land on it
for sure i could almost say that it's so
well designed that it's hard to tell
where the new skull town is going to be
yeah there's no one singular place that
everybody's gone to right now i mean
there is
everybody was exploring for the most
part but even like just thinking ahead
like there's a lot of good hot zones in
this map
and i'm not sure what the next skull
town is going to be at this point
because it's so well designed
and there's also just like a lot of fun
like small easter eggs to discover
too like i thought it was really funny
there was just this moment where we
remembered during the presentation
that olympus has on its map like the
restaurant where revenant
killed loba's parents and i had this
realization at the same time that you
happen to be going like
in that direction and i happen to be
playing as revenant and we had a lobo in
the squad and were like
well what happens when the two of them
go
back to the place where years ago
revenant
killed lopez parents like right in front
of her
i'll see you back here after the match i
have something for you
let's finish this there's all these
other like cool things too like there's
a hammond lab there and if you go there
with horizon
she'll talk about how it wasn't always
called
the hammond labs it used to be named
after someone else since this was
her home like years ago before she got
trapped in the black hole and so there's
all these like really fun
cute and funny like easter eggs to just
discover across the map you can really
tell that they've constructed this map
in mind with the fact that they've now
made it that legends comment on where
they are that they interact with each
other based on who's
in the squad and so the map's been kind
of designed around that mechanic it's
just
full of these little cool things to
discover
respawn has been teasing olympus for a
long time and a lot of
lore has been kind of piling up to this
point and now that there's a whole bunch
of characters able to drop onto the map
i'm sure there's just gonna be a ton of
info drops about what the legends
history is and what happened to them but
you don't have to
completely explore it on your own
there is a new legend that we're getting
with season seven
and her abilities kind of help you
explore this new
vertical space and that's horizon and
specifically
her tactical ability for me personally
horizon
is probably one of my favorite new
season characters i mean lobo was
interesting
i think revenant was really fun but
really weak when he first started out
and then rampart was fairly fun as well
but wasn't really my playstyle
horizon is very movement focused and
very cc focused so it meets crowd
control
those two combined really make me want
to use a tactical and ultimate
more than other legends so her tactical
is a gravity lift which
lifts you up and enemy players this
tactical is
amazing it first of all has a 15 second
cooldown but it has a 10 second active
time so it's only five seconds where you
can't actually use it which is pretty
amazing if you think about it it's great
for just
using in a firefight to dodge gunfire uh
it's great for
reaching really really high areas and
she also has her ultimate which is
everybody's been calling at the zarya
alt right this is just like the black
hole that sucks everybody in
from the time that i played horizon i
didn't really get a good grasp of
exactly how
the black hole works i mean it generally
it pulls everybody in towards the middle
of it
but it's been kind of weird on how
strong that pull is
i just want to get some more time in the
game to really flesh out how that
exactly works
of course her passive really ties in
with everything else too because her
passive reduces her landing lag when she
lands from a really tall area which
everybody else has
i remember back in the day in apex
legends season one and two where
everybody would kick the ground to
reduce landing lag
she has that all the time which is great
and it's really useful for
jumping off at high areas to ambush
people also she has better air control
so she can strafe around areas really
quickly
so she's just a really good movement
based character which really feels good
to play
so of course respawn has been touting as
well that this is their first vehicle
in apex legends the trident is coming
it's a three person vehicle and it's
really cool to drive around but it's not
as op as people have been making it out
to be
yeah i say i've been seeing comments of
people complaining that the
trident's going to make this game like
pubg or
call of duty blackout and that you'll be
able to use the trident to just like run
people
over and get easy kills and it's like
nah nah nah it's not gonna work that way
i don't want to say it's weak but it's
not like something that you want to be
ideally driving into the middle of a
fire fight
at this point going into a firefight
with the trident is pretty bad because
the lag time to get on and off the
vehicle is really really slow
and the damage is shared among all the
players if the shots hit the actual
vehicle itself so everybody takes damage
which makes it tanky but also
you gotta heal which sucks we don't
really know as of right now that it
could be very powerful because
we've seen some legend ability pairing
on it such as caustic traps or even
revenant's totem can be
placed on it you know rampart's turret
can be placed on it as well so
pairing it with abilities which we
didn't test too much i
could make it extremely powerful but as
of right now just on its own it's
not as strong as people say its primary
purpose is to just get
your squad from one side of the map to
the other
that's basically it you can augment its
offensive abilities with specific
legends but
ideally you're just kind of using it
like you would a pathfinder zipline or
wraith portal you're just trying to get
your squad from
point a to point b as quickly as
possible so besides that season seven is
bringing in clubs
a new battle pass with a whole bunch of
new gear also it's going to be bringing
apex legends to steam officially so
that'll bring even more cross-play
players it'll bring in
more people together with the clubs and
the battle pass will obviously give you
lots of new goodies for your legends
so that's our look at season seven
there's a new map there's a new legend
there's a new vehicle there's a whole
bunch of other things as well that are
new that are coming and that's not even
including the patch notes which are
gonna be coming out
explaining all the buffs and nerfs and
other things that are coming to apex
legend season seven
if you like content like this stick
around we've got a whole bunch more
coming including
tests with horizon and a legend guide
with horizon on how to use her and more
to come in the time ahead so
thanks for watching bye you are the apex
[Music]
champions
[Music]
you